[Music]
Victory
know
me why would you bet on G when we got
bet David value taming giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value
look I
[Music]
become what what area quote is 343 is
there an area quote 343 or no 343 I
don't know an area quote I don't know
about that I'm going to check well
today's episode is
343 Ontario Canada what is that Ontario
Canada we have nothing to do with
Ontario Canada right absolutely
absolutely not uh Our Guest today gets
shy when the camera's on something
happens with the camera and he even
expressed this is
his super Kobe chaos comington
uh uh he he's he's got a lot of
different personalities man you see him
fighting calling people out getting a
lot of people pissed off we'll cover
some of that stuff but if there's one
thing you know you know who he is in the
UFC World Kobe Covington it's great to
have you on man thanks for having me on
I appreciate it when honor it's it's
great to have you here I you know I
think one thing most people don't know
and I don't if you kind of like hide it
from people that you don't want people
to know is your level of loyalty and
admiration for President Joe Biden have
you always has it always been a you know
like a private thing because I know
obviously you're wearing this this this
hat called make America great again how
do you feel about President Joe Biden oh
man I I think he's C now I I don't think
that he's still there he can't even ride
a bike anymore so you know the guy has
nothing there I think that even his hand
handlers are just feeding him too many
drugs just to keep him alive every day
it's it's sad to see you know they're
holding him like a little puppet so you
know you see a guy like President Trump
you know he he was at my fight in Vegas
he was at Reno the next day he was at
Iowa the day before then he was speaking
at New Hampshire the next day the guy's
got so much energy like that's what we
need in office right now is a guy like
President Trump who has the energy to to
go all day and not get tired for our
country and and it's so tough to
understand a driver like him like it's
constant going going going going going
and today I I'm sure you saw we'll get
into the stuff with him Colorado he
can't compete and you know what they're
trying to do you with him with him not
being able to by the way you guys see
what the santis when he was asked the
same question what he said can you pull
that up about Colorado when vivec said
I'm going to take he says I'm not maybe
find that clip as well but how you
feeling you just had a fight with uh
with Edwards how you doing yeah I I'm
doing good I mean I didn't get touched
look at my face man I don't got to
scratch on it you do look good you have
no scratch how how' you feel about the
fight though how'd you feel about the
fight I mean looking it back you know I
I I doubled him in strike strikes count
you know I had five minutes of control
time he didn't have one minute so I feel
like I beat him in the fight you know I
broke my foot in like the first 30
seconds of the fight that people don't
know about yet that the x-rays will
start coming out straight up cuz you're
in a boot I mean people can't obviously
see it but you broke your foot in the
first minute of the fight the first
minute of the fight like I had the
picture on my phone like the exact
moment where it landed on his elbow
yeah can we see it yeah for sure of
course first minute and first minute and
Kobe you know right off the like once
once that strike hits Kobe you know in
your head you're like it's broke yeah
you feel you feel it swollen up where
you're just like oh like that at the end
of the first round you're just like man
that hurts like I usually I sit in the
on the stool and I didn't want to sit
down in the stool so this is like the
exact I mean the fight went five rounds
when came down to a decision how do you
fight the next four rounds with a broken
foot the elbow hit the elbow land right
on the right elbow the top of the foot
you know wow and they're telling me that
I think it was the venacular or
something I can't remember the exact
terminology the doctor was telling me
yesterday but he's like yeah you
probably have a fracture in your
venacular vular or something one of
those bones down there there's like 27
meta tarol in your foot so it's tough to
know which how how do you fight the rest
of the fight with a broken foot how do
you even stand up with a broken foot
much l start throwing punches and kicks
and grappling everything was going on
how does that work it it's tough you
know it livits your Mobility like I
couldn't really move after that I was
kind of stuck in place and you know I
was just trying to make sure that I
could get through the fight I didn't you
know I never quit you know you got to
you know I always channel the the
strength of the First Responders in our
military cuz you know that's the the
cloth that I was cut from my my
grandfather flew in the Korean and
Vietnam War so you know if he's looking
down on me he's not going to be happy
unless I fight to the end you know fight
to the death and that's my mentality
when I go into the octagon it's killer
be killed every time well you have you
have that reputation you're your pain
tolerance uh on on when you're going on
these fights and by the way so if you
have the pain here and Leon's throwing
those left kicks to the back of your cuz
you know that part that was marked on
your what is it your right uh yeah right
re right right the hamstrings when you
see that whole thing getting bruised up
which pain is a worse pain is it the
left ankle or is the is it the thigh oh
it was the left ankle for not even close
yeah was I was compensated on it you
know I wasn't really able to step on it
so that's why he was Landing a couple
leg kicks on my right thigh because my
left foot was broken so I was kind of
putting all my weight on my right thigh
and that's terrible when I started
towards the end of the fight I was like
you know what just deal with the pain
and start lifting up your right leg and
start checking some of these kicks you
know and he didn't start kicking after
like the fourth around cuz he started
feeling that I was catching his timing
with the kicks and he didn't want to
break his leg on my knee so now let me
ask you does he know do you think he
knows or he would have no clue that you
broke your left hand like he doesn't
know that that's happening cuz as a
fighter yeah you know are you reading
the other guy's pain Flinch eye movement
to say yeah it looks like it hurts it
looks like cuz you know you've seen
fights where guy breaks his wrist in
boxing yeah and he just doesn't throw it
anymore and you know to go for or you
know the ribs are you know some happened
here so you keep attacking it yeah is he
reading that you're in pain
do you think he knew that you had that
pain no he didn't know cuz I'm good at
masking and not showing weakness and
showing that I had the pain and I
learned early in my career that I
thought when we go to the round at the
end of the round like we're in a vacuum
seal and no one in the world can hear
it's our coaches giving us advice and no
one's going to hear anything but I had
said something in my corner I was like
hey I think I have an injury and they
went back to the other corner on the
broadcast they were like oh he just said
he had an injury he said this is going
on so they attacked that weakness so I
had learned that no matter how I feel
coming back to the end of the round when
I'm sitting on my stool like don't say
anything to the coach even to your own
guys yeah even to my own guys because
the cameras are watching everything
you're saying I got it D wow so now I
just had to keep it myself what a shitty
situation to can you imagine like you
have to talk to somebody be and you're
like I Pro here just be like a secret in
there that I mean that's but that's a
fight that's how your Corners your
trainers your coaches they had no idea
you had broken foot the entire fight
they had no idea until I told him
afterwards when I was limping backstage
they like dude what happened I was like
the first kick that I threw landed on
his elbow and they're like why don't you
tell us I exactly because I've learned
in Prior fights that that the whole
world's going to see that and they're
just going to go tell them on the
broadcast you see how quick social media
is these days so they can literally get
that information within seconds of
seeing it on the broadcast so you know
it's the first time in my career I
didn't sit on the stool after every
round after the five rounds I just
stayed standing up because I could feel
my foot swelling up and I didn't want to
sit down and get comfortable I wanted to
stay standing up and and just dig down
deep to to get through the fight now let
let me ask you fighting Kim Leon Edwards
uh uh uh and and as a fan watching him
right not a technical fighter where I
can't see you know I'm not a technical
where I've been in your world and I can
kind of read what's really going on yeah
from a fans perspective he's not a guy
that's going to sell out the arena okay
people are not going to see him sell out
the arena he doesn't talk he's very
quiet to himself I think he's Jamaican
if I'm not mistake is he is he Jamaican
he's a very friendly guy he seems like a
just chill guy but fighting against him
this guy we had Usman on on here on uh
two days ago right he takes Usman out uh
uh I think two times right when he had
let me see the records here yeah back to
back then it's you nateas okay you know
Doos both of you you did Doos as well
you know he's had some fights what's
what's unique about what's unique about
Edwards his style of fighting purely his
style of fighting I mean yeah purely his
style of fighting because if you're
talking about his personality he has no
redeeming quality qualities the guy I
mean there's more Charisma and that wet
mop in the corner of his room so I mean
the guy is just unlikable he's just he
doesn't he doesn't bring anything to the
table as far as fighting goes so in the
fight you know he he's a well-rounded
fighter but there's nothing special he's
not like a world class in anywhere he's
just pretty good everywhere so he's not
the best fighter you've gone up against
nah he's not the best fighter who's the
best guy you've G gone up against yeah
the best guy I've gone up against is is
you know probably Usman you know he's a
well-rounded fighter he's a good
wrestler so he's a knockout artist he's
a guy who could put you out with one
punch so you know that guy I would say
is a lot more dangerous threat and I
fought him when you know he was in his
absolute prime a couple years ago when
he was number one pound-for-pound so
that was the best guy I've ever fought
you know and you know he he was a way
more dangerous that than Leon look I I
just got this fight four days I don't
have a scratch on my face I mean I I
doubled the the strike count on him you
know he got a couple leg kicks that's
that's how he won is was a couple leg
kicks on me and that was because I was
compensated cuz I was favoring my right
leg because my left foot was broken so
you mentioned uh I think you on Jesse
Waters that you think that they
basically took this decision from you
because you said you support Donald
Trump and that cost you the fight we all
two-part question we we asked Usman
what's more important these days in UFC
the the product or the marketing really
like how good of a fighter are you or
how good of a marketer are you no doubt
you're one of the best in both Edwards
with all due respect he beat you right
so what's the re reality for someone
like Edwards is it he's just a good
product horrible marketer it's the Trump
thing it was stolen from you kind of a
thing get the analogy where is he on
this where are you on this with all that
being said yeah you know I don't think I
was beat last week and I think I gained
a lot more and the fans see the truth of
the fighter and the marketer that I am
the the entertainment aspect that I
bring to this sport you know I make it
fun for the fans they pay their harder
money to watch us so you know as far as
Leon no one was watching are tuning into
the fight to see Leon it was either the
people that absolutely loved me or he
was just boring my haters for a night it
wasn't like he actually brought any
extra fans so but is that is that
sustainable
meaning if he just wins every fight I'm
not saying that he's undefeated yeah if
he just shuts his mouth gets to work but
wins what's wrong with that yeah it's
not enough you know I mean anybody can
just win you know but you need to if
you're really confident in your skills
and you really think you're this alltime
great you know you should should you
should talk about it you should start
telling people this you should start
bringing animosity to these fights and
getting people excited to watch these
fights because you know they're paying
their harder money for this pay-per-view
how are you going to sell a pay-per-view
if you're not saying one thing to the
guy and you're just sitting there quiet
like no one wants to see two guys that
are like oh I respect you what's respect
honor MMA I love you you know let's do
it 100% he's right when you're seeing a
uh uh when you're seeing like I thought
Mayweather and Connor their press
conference is probably the best one of
all time he was slapping him on the head
I think the backpack and all that stuff
I thought that was the best best press
conference uh of all time and there's
been a few of them right like the Daniel
Cormier and uh J Jones the interview
phenomenal intervie Conor Nick Diaz it's
like so uh you know can you count to 10
he says can only count to five right or
hey we're going to talk about money hey
you can take this one out I'll ask me
questions about money that was great
right those moments that you had and
then some of them is
again purely from a fan perspective some
of them you know it's real some of them
you know you're you're you're selling
yeah you you kind of like okay because
the other guy is not responding to any
of it like when Connor did the uh Muslim
thing I think you with with him and khib
when they were going back and forth and
then you saw kabib the guy says Hey
Salam alaykum you know and by the way
Conor congratulations on your proper 12
and says hey you can't say that and then
say thank you to alcohol and well do
something about it right these are
moments that are built to fight but but
I I want to ask you this question cuz I
actually enjoy your performance I enjoy
how you're putting on a show and doing
what you're doing but you know the
comments made about the father I just
want to ask to see what you're going to
say yeah comments made about the father
even Dana comes back and says look you
guys can say whatever trash talk you
want to do but when it comes up to
family stay out of it Conor's done it
with Dustin wife you did it with Leon's
father and Leon's a he's a southp right
cuz we threw it it was perfectly
accurate I don't even know what he threw
out your face he a water bottle he threw
water bottle I'm like how does he how's
he that acting with f then I'm like this
guy's a southpaw I got this makes sense
so what what is the limit you do you
feel bad when you make those comments or
you're like no my job is to sell and I'm
a showman um you know I'm honesty is
everything with me you know like the
truth is always the things that Sting
the most to these Fighters out there so
you know I'm not saying this guy's on
the same level of like a Hitler or just
someone like that but when are we going
to celebrate someone who who's had such
a terrible past you know the guy was
literally a sex trafficker the guy was
literally caught up with with drug lords
and and who are you talking about I'm
talking about Leon's father I mean he
has a troubled criminal past I mean
there's legitimate facts that he did you
know like I'm not going to hide the
truth and I'm not going to feel sorry
for someone who you know put torment and
so much pain in people's lives you know
there's a lot of victims left over from
Leon's father you know whether it was
the women that he sex traffic whether it
was the people that he sold drugs to I
mean it's just I'm not going to feel bad
for someone like that so you know it is
what it is that's that's life you know
I'm just being honest with him you know
dude he's not a good person and you
you're doubling down you're not even you
know pulling back on this you're
doubling down on his father I'm doubling
down why would I feel bad for anything I
say about someone that had is such a
criminal and put so much pain in
people's lives you know I'm not going to
feel bad for someone like that just like
Hitler he was a he was a terrible person
man you comparing his dad to Hitler I'm
not comparing him to Hitler but I'm
saying it's that same level of bad guy
like the guy the guy sold drugs he's sex
sex sex this is this public is this
public information public information
and it's crazy because nobody I mean
just hearing the comment you're like oh
dude you're saying his dad's in Hell
nobody really knows I I didn't know
about the history of his dad I know his
dad was sex trafficking people and
selling drugs I mean if that's public
information so maybe let me ask a
different question because you know we
run a sales organization and we have
meetings that are very very intense and
call outs and all this stuff and we have
have a rule call out whatever you want
don't hit family don't hit spouse you're
fine okay and there'll be the
talking that takes place now obviously
there's no fights it's not a real fight
that we're talking about do you get a
call and say Hey you crossed the line
like you can't say that again or in UFC
no one's going to call you to tell you
anything it's just if you want to say it
say it nothing's off the table is that
kind of how the culture is in UFC or
will you get a call at times yeah I mean
you'll definitely get a call at times if
if you're racist or go after someone's
religion but I would never go after
those two things you know I I'll expose
things that need to be exposed because
it's the truth and it's honesty like you
can look up the public records about his
dad and it's not my fault he's the one
that put him in the Limelight in the
first place and tried to make it a
sympathetic uh figure oh I lost my
father oh this and that and they made it
feel like oh let's give uh Leon sympathy
for this like that's not something you
should give someone's sympathy for if my
dad was doing things like that I would
call him out on that too I'd be like
dude I you know he probably deserves to
be six feet under because you know he he
he did a lot of bad things to people in
this life so you know I'm not going to
feel bad or celebrate that person like
he's a hero cuz that guy's not a hero
he's a villain he's a he's a terrible
person he did Terrible Things apparently
he was shot and killed when Leon was 13
so how much do you think this had
adverse effect on you because Leon said
he was completely enraged emotional
crying this is after he threw the water
bottle obviously there was a a little
tussle right there and he said that you
know it breaks my heart that that he
uses my father as entertainment and he
said about you he said that he's a great
competitor but he's a dirty human being
this is his response to you so with all
that being said like have you guys
spoken after the fight how does it work
does there any apologies or it's like
you go to hell no I mean I didn't
break his bank account I might have
might have broke his feelings he might
be hurt but even Dana White said after I
said that the paper viws jump 25%
instantly this is Dan's words and quotes
so you know whether you want to say it's
for entertainment and for selling
pay-per-views you know I made Leon a lot
more money just talking about it so you
know what what no matter what you want
to think of it whether good or bad you
know I put more money in Leon's bank
account and he should be thanking me for
that Kobe how much of this is cuz you
know
like uh Too Short uh not too is it too
short yeah too short you know the rapper
Too Short back in the days I don't know
if you remember to short so yeah to
short you know every record he would do
would said this is my final album six
months no no this is the final about 12
times it was always we buying his final
album but it's a great marketing another
guy that was a great marketer he says
when he would hang out with Tupac he
says on any given day you had no idea
what personality would show up right one
minute it would be The Party Guy let's
go girls let's go you know one minute is
the philosopher did you know the
hegelian dialectic and did you know what
one minute is the Revolutionary guy you
know we're going to go take over the
world and it's it's not fair what
they're doing to our people one minute
it was the gangster right one minute it
was the artist right so you you didn't
know who that person was going to be on
any given day do you feel you have a
little bit of that because you know like
u
u Usman sees you at the airport you guys
run into each other what a nice guy talk
to me gentleman the whole night and then
if I see you in the airport again I'm on
to B right is that an act or is it you
know you don't know what personality of
Kobe is going to show up on any given
day which one do you think it cuz
sometimes creatives have multiple
personalities it's not just one thing
that it is which one thing is you no
there's definitely no act or personality
with me I just turn it up to 11 when I
get into business and r a camera I'm not
going to be nice you know we're getting
locked in a cage to kill that person
that's what the people want to celebrate
they want to see blood lust they want to
see Fighters getting broken bones and
sent to the hospital so why am I going
to feel bad about some words that I'm
saying and and the words I'm saying I I
believe they're true and I I stand
behind those with conviction so I'm not
going to feel bad for exposing the truth
to the world and people are sensitive
you know it's get a helmet like my
friend Candace Candace Owens says get a
helmet and and big deal get over it so
you know there's no personality I'm just
not afraid to to speak the truth and
when it's time to do business and and
it's fight weak and the cameras are on
I'm I'm you know I'm going to say things
that I feel are true and that opponent
has a chance to go in the Octagon do
whatever you want to me he had he had 25
minutes to do whatever he wanted to take
his frustrations out on me legally and
he wasn't able to do anything there's
not a scratch on my face it was it was
an easy fight I can't believe they paid
me that much money to to go fight that
guy I got a follow-up question for you
but we before we do let's go to the
sponsor here American Heart for
gold so look I've been in the financial
industry since 911 the day before 9911
and I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
these years is gold I love having a
percentage of my network in Gold that I
have access to in case of many different
things that's why we chose to work with
our new sponsor American Harford gold if
you have retirement funds that you
cannot afford to lose American Harford
gold will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
hardford gold a precious metal dealer
you can trust they have the finest
products amazing customer service and a
buyback commitment they've earned a star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on a link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 so you know president Trump okay um
he gets up there he's comfortable
calling everybody outse well what what
did you just say about uh McCain I want
my soldiers to not be prisoners of
War you know and then the next thing you
know he gets heat from there right and
then he calls out fake news calls out
aasta calls out everybody and he's
nonstop about it right okay when you do
that you know uh uh you know certain
people when you joke with them and
they're sarcastic towards you but then
all of a sudden you're sarcastic towards
them yeah and they're kind of like hurt
wait a minute bro what's what's wrong
with you're good dishing it but you're
not good taking it right yeah how much
of it is also for you where it's like
you know they're going to say stuff to
you right after the fight you know he
didn't look good it's time to retire
Michael Chandler he's got to be in
prelims moving forward his fights it's
no longer main fight you know Patty is
saying if I see him in the streets I'm
going to you know whatever and then
Strickland talking about I can't believe
what he just said and Strickland wanting
to say things to you yeah H what is your
reaction cuz your your immediate
reaction right now smile on your face do
you get off of it or you're like I'm
getting the world to react to me or
you're not even thinking about it
yeah I mean I don't really think about
it but obviously my first reaction to it
now is just laughing because all those
people there's no uh substance they're
they're talking the talk they're not
going to walk the walk you know Patty
they gave him two heroin had addicts to
fight back to back and he didn't even
beat the last one he fought this guy
jarro Gordon a legit heroin addict and
he didn't even win the fight the world
knew he lost that fight so you know if
he didn't have a bull cut in an accent
nobody would care about Patty that's the
only reason they like him is a bull cut
in accent not even a good fighter he'll
never be a top 30 Fighter the closest
he'll ever get to fighting for a world
title is if he got on his knees and came
and sniffed my
Jock It's facts but he's a good marketer
Tru he's a good marketer he just has a
bull cut in accent he's not even
a and accent so hard he thought he was
from Ireland I'm like no he's from
England bro same so wild but you
know he cut the bull cut now he's got
like uh braids oh man oh well I mean for
the fight no they get cornrows for the
for the fights cornrow my apologies I
don't want to you know culture appro
Chandler said you know prelin and
Strickland is you know he he he he just
straight up stopped he wanted to make a
comment about what you said about Leon's
father yeah I mean look at the stuff
that Sean Strickland does he should
worry about uh figuring out his justice
system situation over in Vegas pistol
whipping some guy in the middle of the
street and almost shooting the guy dead
that was just walking around drunk
around his neighborhood so the guy's at
a train wreck that's the type of guy
that might do some Eddie Guerrero stuff
to his family in the future you got to
be careful I you know that guy's he's
brain dead he's been hit in the head too
many times so he you know I think he's
going to have some some problems in the
future and then Michael Chandler who I
mean the guy was getting knocked out in
Bellator the guy's a complete scrub
what's his UFC record like one and four
like we're talking about that my win
percent in the my win percentage in the
UFC is like over 90% like it's just you
know I'm an all-time great in this
division I've done things in this
division that people aren't ever going
to do I mean I'm the only fighter to
ever go to the White House and hang out
with the city president I'm the only one
to ever get the first family front row
I'm the only one to ever have you know a
president out there supporting him
dapping me up before I walk in the
Octagon so he can keep talking all he
wants but there's no substance another
guy that's just all talk and no walk can
I ask a question so um Kobe the when it
comes to Trump and I'm pretty sure with
you that's how you know love or hate
there's nobody I don't I've never met
somebody that's just like yeah Trump you
know I'm cool with him it's either love
or hate what what was the moment for you
Kobe cuz I know I know what it is what
what it was for me about the country and
and the movement and the voice it
couldn't have been I'm not saying it
could have been anybody but what was
that moment for you where you're like oh
like this this is this President is
this is who I I connect with and then
that phone call you beat uh Tyrone
Woodley you're sitting in there post
fight you're you're getting interviewed
and all of a sudden somebody comes and
gives you a phone and it's the president
of the United States is Trump how what
was that moment for you co and how does
that feel sitting in an interview and
the president of the United States wants
to talk to
you I mean the moment where I really was
just like man that's so admirable was
just seeing that he gave up his you know
rich and wealthy lifestyle to to come
fight for America the guy could be
having his toes in the sand with Midas
giving him my Ties on the beach every
single day but he doesn't want to do
that he he's the only president in
history who his net worth has went down
after being in office so who else can
say that all these other guys like the
bidens you know the the the clintons you
know the their net worth goes up
substantially the Obamas they go up
substantially after in office they're
they use all these uh politicians and
all these lobbyists and they just make
money from them so that's when I
respected Trump the most most just
seeing that he was willing to give up
his lifestyle his net worth his his you
know his great business tactics that he
has to save America you know to save
against all these communist swamp
creatures that are in DC right now so
you know that's when I gain the most
respect and just to see all the Loyalty
that he show me I mean he's calling me
after a fight you know he's giving me
advice before fights he's you know invi
me over to his house at Maro to have
dinner like before my fights you know
just the amount of loyalty that he show
me like just some nobody fighter like
he's the most famous person on Earth he
doesn't have to call me and waste his
time he has the busiest schedule of any
man on Earth right now so just seeing
how loyal to Loyal he is to me just
shows he's just a regular dude just the
the guy next door that that respects
people and if you show him loyalty he's
going to show it to you in return does
that when you know that he's in the
audience uh Kobe does that Fu does that
make you like cuz I can I can like if
these guys come to see me perform I know
on the back of my head doing stand up
I'm like okay I know exactly pets is he
laughing is Adam laughing you know I see
Rob shiny head I'm like you know what I
mean I'm looking around I'm booing in
the
back throwing Tomatoes when you when
you're fighting bro and I you know where
he's at everybody knows where Trump is
at does that fuel you does that does
that amp you up that you know that this
guy's there it does it does amp me up
but it's also a lot of pressure you
don't you don't want to let that guy
down you know especially all the things
he's done for me and my career and done
for this country I mean he's
single-handedly fought back against the
swamp swamp and exposed all the
corruption of the Democrats you know
these guys will go to any link to to
take back this country they they don't
want America to be free and and fair
they you know they don't want the people
to be in control of America they want to
have all this communist stuff you know
look at how they shut down our country
for a fake pandemic just so they could
do control the mail and ballots and then
you know now they're letting our border
just be completely wide open so they can
use those illegals to V for vote for
them but they're still losing in the
polls and you know weaponizing the
justice system that's third world
dictator type thing so you know Trump's
the only man standing between them and
America and you know he loves America
more than he loves himself and more than
he loves his family like that's how much
he cares about America and changing
America forever so we need America back
we need uh Donald Trump back in office
he's going to restore Democracy in
America Kobe I got to tell you bro what
you're doing with the Trump and the
magga brilliant tell you what why uh we
were at UFC uh in Miami yeah when was
that this past summer couple months let
me tell you that this was the first time
I've been to a UFC fight okay I've been
in that Heat arena thousand times all of
a sudden we
hear yeah they don't announce him they
don't announce he's not on camera what's
going on they're like Trump just showed
up crowds going nuts we're like oh
so at at that moment I was like oh
UFC loves them some Trump okay it
was impressive so I know you're saying
that me possibly you being a trump
supporter CS you this fight but from a
marketing standpoint from an alignment
standpoint for who you who your brand is
this is on brand right so never
apologize for that whether you people
like Trump not TR Trump this has helped
your brand no doubt I don't know any
other UFC fighters marketing make
America great again like you so but I
but I think he's a 100% true
believe act 0% an act right so number
one when are you running for congress
number two if Trump wins are you're
going to take a position as white house
but most importantly are you the Donald
Trump of the
UFC yeah I do believe I'm the Donald
Trump of the UFC he's my biggest role
model role model he's my mentor and he's
someone that I really look up to so I
try and model my career after a lot of
things that he's done and you know I
definitely would like to run for
Congress in a few years you know I think
I'd be the perfect fighter you know I'm
not a guy that's going to sell out to
the establishment I I'm a self-made man
from nothing you know I came from a blue
collar family in Oregon who had
absolutely nothing who lived in the
trailer parks now a multi-million dollar
athletes so you know I think that I can
do great things for this Republican and
conservative movement that other guys
won't be able to do because they don't
have the funds and means to do it so you
know I appreciate everything Donald
Trump's done for me I'm a True Believer
I'll I'll die fighting for that man like
I've given up my platform for him I'm
completely shadowbanned on one of the
platforms you know that's the biggest
platform I'm not going to talk about it
doesn't deserve it but you know I even
had the UFC try and reach out to him be
like hey why is he Shadow ban and they
won't even tell him they won't even you
can't even search me in some of the
search bars the only one that people can
find me on is really X because Elon Musk
has restored free speech in America so
you know I can't say the same for
Zuckerberg he's done some pretty nasty
things he believes in communism and you
know he's he's in kahoots with China as
well I and I mean he put what $500
million into the last election which is
crazy for for mailing ballots and all
these places he that's I mean Zuckerberg
spent what was it Rob $500 million on
the that's absolutely if and by the way
you know what he is he's a Democrat so
where do you think that that money and
all that thing was going for look that
can't even find my my profile I have
I've had over a million followers for
well this is on Instagram right now if
you type in your name to all my fan
pages stop it I I was but put in your
actual like put it together so it's not
despicable no but oh but you have to put
it together why do you have to put it
together I don't know Miss the end go
miss the end just go like Kobe Covington
like almost there so you got to spell
out the whole entire name no just
tagging you before I came in here Kobe
it wouldn't let me find you I'm like I
had to put it in twice I'm like where
the hell is Kobe when did that start
that started four years ago when I put
up my picture with Donald Trump as my
head head profile picture by the way you
know if I in look okay Patrick mahes
let's just see PA just PA yeah it's the
first one can we can we do a quick
little thing right here like don't
realize how three like super famous
names and see how it pops up yeah
Patrick is first no no by the way put
put Dana put Dana like to see not even
the right there pops up Dana Dana White
pops up boom
unbelievable try something like go in a
complete different space go to Anthony
all my profiles that have 500 followers
unbelievable type in Anthony Edwards
like uh right there he just pops up all
you have to do was Anthony he pops up
yeah the blue check mark why why do you
think that is though do you think you
think it's purely political it's purely
political it's it's completely their
agenda they're trying to silence Free
Speech they don't want anybody that has
that opposes their narrative you know
and and if you go if you don't believe
everything that the Liberals say and you
don't believe that it's flame and yawn
even though it's it's and trying to
shove down your throat then they'll
sense of you they will not allow free
speech in America and that's what our
youth and our kids need to see like this
is the stuff they need to see they don't
need to have all this this woke CRT
critical race Theory agenda shov down
their throats and and not be able to see
the other side of it the Republican
conservative side so you know it's it is
what it is I'm glad I would stand up I
don't need social media to know that I'm
famous or know that I'm standing for
what is right I know I'm standing for
what's right because look it I don't
even like really talk so much political
I'm just showing my support for Trump
that's all I'm doing is you know I
respect Trump as a businessman as a man
as a father as a family guy the guy is
just a great person overall and look I
put up a picture with them and that's
why they're censoring me they won't
allow my uh profile to be viewed by the
masses they want to shadowban me so it's
just disgusting it's despic yeah that
that's that's a I wonder who else
they're doing that with you know the
fact that somebody can't find the name
right off the bat and have to type the
whole thing in have to put it together
for it to pull up yeah deeply concerning
okay uh let me let me uh go to you know
couple things here with while we're on
the topic LeBron LeBron walks in you
made a couple comments on it on what he
did uh and and I know you talked about
it with Fen nek boys all those guys and
you know you're you know walks in I
think this kids a game or something like
that and then he grabs a seat doesn't
even stand up you're thinking maybe
after you get to your seat then you're
going to stand up at least pay some kind
of respect yeah nothing and you know you
know you you see that why is that
important so maybe maybe a person on the
other side's goingon to say look he just
chose to sit down why is that important
to somebody on the left right and the
middle for the biggest star in
basketball to stand up during the
national anthem yeah why it's important
is because the place that he's made all
his money and his billion dollar net
worth is the country that he's sitting
down for that that national anthem the
the fallen heroes of the families that
supported his uh Freedom here in America
so he could Chase his dreams and have
his opportunity in the NBA he would be
nothing without this country trying go
make that money over in China try and
make that money in Korea and all these
other countries that aren't free no you
couldn't do it so the fact that he's
just spitting on the face of all our all
our service members you know all our
military veterans past and present is
just it's the most despicable thing I've
ever seen in my life the guy is just you
know he's just a shill why do you think
he's not you think it's intentional it's
intentional why do you think he's not
standing up because you know he's paid
and bought for by a Chinese he's a
Chinese finger puppet you know he's got
all his sweat shops over in China where
he makes his hundreds of millions of
dollars off merchandise so he's told to
to to you know be have a muzzle on him
and not talk don't think he's told you
think that's him meaning you know you
know because I'm there's a lot of guys
in the NBA that are you know somebody
can say well you know some owners Mark
cubin defended this this up but he still
stands up there's a lot of guys that are
still paid by China that still stand up
why do you think he's not standing up I
think he's just completely paid in B for
and I I just don't think he's
intelligent enough to to formulate his
own response to why he's not he just
it's just straight money going to his
bank account you think he loves America
no he hates America he he sits down
every time there's a national anthem
playing he he shits on all our First
Responders he he's literally called hits
on our First Responders the people that
protect us and keep us free oh oh police
BLM oh they're so bad but then anytime
there's any situation OH police help me
help me help my James family come
protect us and and make sure you know
none of my crazy fans come after me but
then he'll go on on the internet and
just talk about how police are so bad
and and you know he'll talk about a 1%
of a 1% of a situation and try and
despise them like they're the bad guys
when when our First Responders our our
law enforcement is our heroes and our
backbone of our country in America has
he ever given a positive shout out to
Cops no I just saw this tweet from 2021
remember when he deleted the Tweet about
police shooting uh at mck
Bryant James is inciting violence on
Ohio police this is this what was a
tweet that he had did I'm so damn tired
of seeing black police black people
killed by police I took the Tweet down
because it's being used to create more
hate this isn't about one officer it's
about an entirety of a system uh uh like
I Wonder has he ever gone up and say hey
I just want to thank everybody here the
the the service I want to thank the
military personnel I want to thank our
officers our firefighters or First
Responders absolutely not have you ever
heard him say that absolutely not and
and Kobe you you you hit the nail on the
head just the the and it this goes to
show how much China and I've said this
on multiple podcasts he's obviously
owned by China a lot of the athletes
here are who is the the wrestler I that
John Cena John Cena said something
sticking up for the poor people of
Taiwan and then he had to say an apology
in Mandarin because he knows that that's
the that's the hand that Fe that which
he somehow speaks fluently fluently but
and and then mind you dude and I've said
this so many times China owns are asses
they fly spy balloons they own they own
Biden they own LeBron and bro the beauty
about this country and Kobe I'm a
veteran Pat's a veteran you you have the
freedom here to do that you can do that
you could sit there he can make snow
angels on the court but guess what
you're a shitty person for doing it I
have zero respect okay he's an athlete
people like well you got to respect this
game I don't give a about the game
I'm not even a basketball fan but you're
a shitty person to go in there while
everybody's standing up and respecting
uh the national anthem and you're
sitting there that's a he's he's letting
the world terrible example to kids
that's what I was just going to say kids
are watching and going hey if LeBron
James and people don't realize how many
millions Pat how many millions of
children in this country know and they
see that and they go oh you know what
he's doing it to hell with America we're
evil we're way for some people that are
watching this who are Die Hard LeBron
fans okay they're like oh you guys are
being unfair I would love to see a video
clip of him giving a shout out and
thanking cops or milary firefighters or
personel I'd love to see it I've never
seen it ever never seen it especially
when he uses their service so constantly
you know police police security to
protect his family so the guy puts a
ball in a hoop you play a kids game
you're not you're not you haven't solved
world hunger you haven't solved cancer
well stop acting like you're so
righteous and and you're perfect dude
that guy's not a role model the role
models are military guys like you who
who fought for our freedoms and defended
our our country's land you know First
Responders who you know protect our our
communities protect our our you know all
the big people in this country and those
are those are the RO models that our
kids should be looking up to not these
athletes who put a ball in a hoop how
does that make you so special you Colby
maybe there's a deeper narrative here
you know because right now I'm picturing
Colby versus LeBron right but I'm going
deeper I'm seeing UFC versus the NBA
what do I mean so we all remember during
2020 during the bubble no League was
more woke or social justice Warriors
than the NBA yep everyone like literally
changed the name on their jerseys to
whatever cause they had end racism the
current F whatever whatever it was I
think a couple guys had um with her I
don't know what's going on out there
yeah but UFC so that I mean even Golden
State Warriors when they won the
championship they wouldn't go meet Trump
in the white house so I think it's fair
to say that the NBA is left I don't I
don't see Trump going to NBA games no I
see Trump showing up to UFC fights I see
a lot of UFC guys you know even MOS
who's not your buddy these days we can
touch on that at this point he loves him
some Trump and a lot of guys are kind of
I assume are in that camp so from a
deeper perspective the UFC the mentality
the ideology there versus the NBA what
they stand for the relationship with
China not going to visit the White House
Adam Silver versus Dana White there's a
bigger compelling story here give us the
bigger narrative NBA versus UFC yeah the
bigger narrative is you know Dana White
Hunter Campbell the guys that run the
UFC Free Speech absolutist you know they
believe in us not being muzzled we
should be able to say whatever they want
you know in the NBA Adam Silver tells
them nope you're going to stay you're
going to say the left narrative and
that's there's only going to be one way
that we're going to talk about because
those are the guys that are paying our
bills those are the ones that we have
our merchandise deals with those are the
ones that we have our our TV deals with
over in China so you know NBA is not a
free League like I have guys that have
reached out me to me on Instagram from
the NBA they're like man we appreciate
what you're standing up for Colby but we
we can't say the same thing cuz then
we'll lose our livelihood then we won't
have our checks to to pay for our our
houses and pay for our food on the table
for our family so I feel bad for these
guys where they're not allowed to
express their real thoughts and feelings
they have to they have to listen to what
you know the narrative that shoved down
their throat from the left in the NBA
and that there's one way and if you go
up against it then you're going to lose
your job I mean look at what they did to
Kyrie Irving they painted him out in the
street like he was the biggest villain
of all time the guy just you know
believe in free speech believe in know
his own you know right to choose what he
should do with his body my body my
choice he's not like a guy like Travis
Kelce out there who's believing in oh
I'm paid off by fiser guys get two shots
at the same time that's the healthiest
thing you could ever do with your life
dude two sh shots I mean I didn't get
the vaccine I don't believe in vaccine
but I'm not against someone that does
believe in vaccine if you did get the
vaccine you should probably just get one
at a time because if there's adverse and
and wrong effect in it then how you
going to know which one's the cause of
it if you're getting two at the same
time that's irresponsible Travis Kel is
one of the biggest pieces of of all
time the fact that he's advising people
to do that you know he's not doing it
he's just telling people to do it
because he's getting paid off in B four
by fizer it's disgusting and how much do
you think Taylor Swift has this because
Taylor DWI is Taylor Swift is sort of
the darling of the left dude this guy
won two Super Bowls he seems like a
rugged badass dude you know arguably the
greatest tight end playing today uh how
much is the left the narrative the
Taylor Swift coming into Travis Kelce
and infusing their ideology on him you
think oh yeah 100% but that you know
that's a fake relationship that's just
the left putting these two powerful
figures together so they can be role
models and teach these nasty things to
kids of today you know that it looks you
can tell that the left is just going
after the most famous people they can
the athletes celebrities entertainers
and they're just getting them to shove
their narrative down these kids' throats
wait what guys I just searched something
right now based on what you just said
okay I I if you don't know the answer
I'm really curious to know what you're
going to say what do you think he got
paid for from fizer for this commercial
100 million no no one's going to pay
that kind of money I'm saying I'm saying
for for the whole campaign let me tell
you something for 100 million I'm
jaing me typically you get a cost like
half a million bucks a million bucks
that's a big deal right what do you
think got paid for that okay now that's
like that what five million what do you
think got that's a lot I I've not heard
of $5 million deals for a Travis Kelce
what do you think I paid for that I mean
listen for you to go around and be the
the spokesperson for and you're the face
of the NFL and you're dating Taylor
Swift whatever number you like dude I
would give this number million 20 are
you kidding meow did you guys know this
I did not know I just Googled it right
according to a report from Andrew pit
cash Travis Kelce was offered a strong
incentive to take part of a fiser
promotion the Kansas City Star is stated
stated to have made a massive $20
million wow from the advertisement Oh
weird oh my God I had no clue and then
think about this but and you
nailed look look at this look at this
tactic and I said this yesterday you got
to tip your hats to to Democrats they
recruit his ass they make them date
she's a a Democrat you wait in 6 months
guess what she's gonna say to all her
what are they called her swifties hey
guys if Donald Trump makes it hope to
God don't vote they're evil vote for
whoever new Sumer whoever you know how
many how influential her voice is going
to be for a vote and that's the tactic
get nine Jabs and vote for the left
they're not stupid let me tell you
something let me tell you something you
know I I would never mess with the UFC
those guys are badasses you do not want
to mess with the
Swifty so check this out look look at
this go go go on the article and go a
little lower watch this here go a little
lower okay zoom in right there on the
top top tweet on the top tweet right
above it keep no no the other way the
other way so Kelsey typically makes 5
million a year from endorsements and $14
million salary these endorsements are
Nike Thai T-Mobile Old Spice Walgreens
McDonald's Papa John's Sleep Number and
Dick Sporting Goods one company fiser
paid him four times the amount of all of
those big companies paid him so oh my
gosh I don't like that man 20 million
bucks yeah this is no no this is exactly
why when I talk to VI and RFK I say
somebody as a president you have to take
you have to not allow big Pharma to pay
this type of money put for people
because you're going to be tempted to
like he just said what he said I'll take
$100 million even Adam's like I'll take
$100 million for this but imagine how
many other kids are sitting there saying
yeah that's my guy he's dating Taylor
Swift I'll take the vaccine I'll do this
I'll do that and what are the effects on
that
myocarditis let's say it's 1 in a th000
let's say it's 1 in 10,000 let's say
it's 1 in 100,000 you're okay with that
I don't know about that man 20 million
bucks I I thought it was honesty I
thought the number was going to be a
million to 2 and half million Max when I
saw that commercial I thought it was a
spoof come out Kobe when I saw that
commercial I'm like this is a comedy
spoof grab yourself twice get out of
here by the way the reason I even know
about this is because you know who
called him out initially was Aaron
roders yeah on the Pat McAfee show yeah
but let me tell you something I believe
in premarket capitalism make your
decisions if you want online you want to
go basically literally sell out to Big
farmer and take your $20 million you do
what you got to do Travis but we have
the right to be like uh-uh
hold on not
I'm so grateful that people even found
this 20 million he made 5 million go
back to those Brands we don't know about
this how is this not public information
we these are some of the bigger biggest
brands in the world Nike tide T-Mobile
Old Spice Walgreens McDonald's I mean
this is massive billion dollar marketing
budget why all that does not equal what
fer did why why even why even play
football for 14 million a year the hell
with getting a concussion and getting
your brain messed up just keep saying
hey next year be like hey guys guys get
three more Jabs $20 million a year why
are you playing football not a year for
one commercial by way so by the way you
know some of the guys in in all sports
watch this and you know we we talk to
these guys you know some of the names we
won't say publicly but you know what
they're thinking right now they're
probably calling their manager hey
man for
sure
commercial but think think about how
tarnished fizer's brand is that whatever
their marketing budget was before need
to double it triple it 10x it prior to
whatever happened with Co if they called
fiser he's like yeah for half a million
bucks whatever $20 million they come
knocking down your door and they throw
in a free Swifty CD dude you're going to
you're going to consider that
that's 20 million for one like half a
day of work is all campaign yeah wow
that's unbelievable I'm telling you I
want one law for president to push 100
out of all the countries in the world
near 200 countries in the world only two
big Pharma to advertise we've talked
about this a number of times it's us and
New Zealand we just need one president
come in and say Hey Big Pharma you can
no longer pay Travis Kelce 20 million
bucks to do something like this not big
Pharma okay well that's not fair don't
you believe in capitalism if you believe
in the capitalism you believe in let
cigarettes be sold on you know how come
cigarettes don't do advertisement how
come tobacco there's a lot of companies
that can't do advertisement on TV I
think these guys after covid have proven
they don't they should not have the free
to throw money at everybody and say go
advertise 20 million ban One commercial
you know he's not really actually taking
two Jabs I guess talks about health is
his Cornerstone of of his career you
know the things he puts in his body for
for his diet you know his his work ethic
in the in the gym lifting weights those
are the things that but they're trying
to brainwash these kids like oh take the
jab this is what's going to make you
healthy this is what's going to make you
a star NFL player so that that's
gaslighting let me ask you bro let me
ask you a question what's your Vibes if
we go out and we're watching you know uh
uh we're watching we're hanging out out
there play playing cards and Kelsey's a
neighbor he comes him and his brother
would you get the Vibes of them being
conservatives or
liberals I get conservative I get
conservative I do too too right the
brothers like you know him and his wife
they they're doing family the way they
were raised I get conservative Vibes
yeah for sure for 20 million bucks be a
Democrat for a day you're sell yeah but
you're selling
milli no I disagree ready for this ask
him ask him if if for for 50 million
would you do that commercial no I
wouldn't do that for any bingo you can't
do that you can't sleep at
night let me let me you've said this a
number of times yeah okay you got
everybody's the price let me ask a
question I ask Bradley Martin you ready
yeah for how much money will you cut
your dangling off and be transgender no
everybody's got a price to go for how
much money 200 million hang on a stay on
this topic would you do it for a billion
any limbs would you do it for a billion
bucks I'll cut my left pinky toe off no
doubt but do you understand so when you
say everybody has a price they don't
have a price there's how about this how
about this the majority the vast
majority of people do have a price they
don't have a price but hear me out for a
second it just means this is not a hill
you want to die on for you yeah you're
like hey s cast a million dollar fiser
I'll take it maybe you would take that
sponsorship right not enough but okay
okay but what I'm saying is but maybe
you would take for and I don't know if
you're going to get $2 million pull cuz
you don't have that kind of pull that
kelse has you're not dating Taylor yeah
but but all I'm saying to you is maybe
you'll say I'll take the million bucks
because to you I don't give a
what's the big deal I've taken flu shots
I've taken this when I travel I have to
take this shot that shot but there are
people that wouldn't take it if you gave
them all the money in the world there
are people literally that wouldn't take
it that even that statement everybody
has a price tag gets the populace to
believe well I have a price tag no I
don't think that's the right mindset to
think everybody has a price tag you may
in certain areas you don't give a
about but I think you have to have more
you know certain values and principles
that you're not willing to compromise
it's disappointing because I like his
play I actually like him as a guy and I
like him and his brother I like the fact
that they are you know they seem like
the type of guy you would actually enjoy
their company you know what I'm saying
kelse don't give me the vibe of like you
wouldn't enjoy their company SN people
they give me a gronowski Vibe right
let's just you probably fun to party
with him maybe not his brother was a
good guy to party with but he comes
across this guy that you'd want to party
with I'll tell you 20 million bucks wow
I'll give you a quick response and this
is why I say everyone has a price um I
firmly believe that I don't think Travis
Kelce is aligned with whatever this
narrative is on the left but when they
come to you you've been in these
spotlights before you've probably been
approached by all sorts of people
they're like Travis Kelce you know two
years years ago nobody knew your
freaking name now you've won two Super
Bowls Let's Make a Deal buddy what you
got in mind all right well you're Soul
how would you like to be the most famous
player in the NFL what what do you mean
yeah Tom Brady's retired you know
there's someone else that can pick up
the mantle how about we throw in $20
million to shoot one commercial all
right go on what's it for fizer I don't
know about that how about we'll make it
a little sweeter for you uh name the
biggest hottest pop star in the world
that maybe you'd want to be seen out
with constantly cardi B no no no no CI
okay you know maybe Taylor Swift shows
up to your uh Arrowhead Stadium for a
game randomly and you guys maybe you
guys fall in love by you know accident
who knows maybe maybe you're on the
cover of people maybe you're the biggest
show in the world just maybe Travis
Kelce at some point even Travis Kelce
who's a multi-millionaire I think he's
got a 40 50 m million dollar net worth
He Ain't No slouch
even he has a price so that's my point
here is that when I say everybody has a
price maybe it's not literally everybody
you're making sense but what I'm saying
is for the right deal even someone Adam
you I think it validated the one my
point that even Travis Kelce is willing
to sell out for the money for the fame
for the chick all that for for what
though for this hill it's not an
important Hill to him what what do you
think Kobe when it comes down to
everybody's got a price like if if these
guys called you with a fat check what
check would you say yes to there's not a
check I would say yes to you know for me
and I I know that everybody doesn't have
a price cuz some people have a
conscience and to have that on your
conscience living every day that you're
advising people that this is healthy and
this is what you should do for your body
when people are dying by the masses from
heart attacks I mean look at LeBron
Jones James son didn't he have like
Cardiac Arrest at 17 years old 17y old
little you know super athlete in the
James family having Cardiac Arrest
that's unheard of you never heard about
that 20 years ago before these Jabs came
out so no amount of money am I going to
be able to live with and and feel good
about myself like I I wouldn't be able
to sleep at night I go to bed thinking
man I'm just fooling everybody in in
America right now I'm I'm leading them
down a path of Destruction I I just
couldn't live with myself with that
there's no amount of money I already
have enough money where where I came
from a million dollars was going to set
me up for life so you know there there's
no amount of money I buy let me ask you
this you're a man of principal no doubt
knowing what you know profession
athletes even UFC for the that amount of
money lifechanging for most guys how
many people are at least taking that
call and being like all right I'll
listen to what you guys got to say fill
in the blank contral UFC in UFC or even
in professional sports you're you're
saying that you wouldn't do it whatever
the number is these guys get paid 50
Grand a fight to get their face
mashed in right they're calling you for
$20 million how many guys are picking up
that phone oh yeah every single one n
you know N Out of that's my point you're
yeah but that's in the UFC where they
don't make you know paychecks like in
the NFL in the NFL you know minimum wage
those guys to sit on the bench are
making a million a year so you know you
could be a field goal kicker and you're
making 3 to five million a year so
that's not enough money like what but
the reality is most NFL players are out
of the league broke within 3 to five
years that's the that's the NFL and
that's the reality of it NBA I think
it's five years plus yeah but these guys
what they need to understand is I mean
you know you're 35 you're still in the
you know Prime of your career most guys
by the time they're 30 they're done zero
more money ever to be made in their
entire life yeah okay and that's the
reality of an athlete it's kind of like
a hot model it's like by the time you're
30 cut it off yeah so you got to make it
now because if Travis Kelce doesn't do
this thing now nobody's going to be
thinking about Travis Kel 35 is not
prime no he I'm saying Colby I'm not
saying you I'm not talking I'm saying
most guys are done by 30 any right you
talking about in The Other Sports in any
sport yeah so so so yeah I mean look
again it's what hill like for example
khib you know what what everybody
learned about khib during
UFC to him number one is not money it's
religion oh there's no question about it
right and and everybody learned like
this is not an act yeah he's not trying
to sell tickets guess what say something
about my religion my country and my
family one more time I swear to God say
it one more time look what I'm going to
do to you right gu what you're like oh
this guy's not playing right Conor
found out you know it's okay I thought
he would just selling tickets and all
this other stuff no uh to some they're
like I don't give a I'll take the
vac and by the way keep in mind up until
we had kids dude I probably been
vaccinated more than anybody at this
table probably you and I you and I
probably have the most vacc I got dude
every freaking week in the army they
were giving us something
new we get these air guns guns and we we
we would they would tell us they're like
just so you know you're military
property for the contract that you sign
that's what GI stand for government
issue and you move a littleit it's a
scar right remember those what was
that all about so like hey all I want
you to I want to tell you is don't
Flinch yes right and Pat did you have a
choice no I didn't have government
forment is by the way not only did I not
have a choice more importantly I didn't
give a yeah that's what I'm trying
to tell you I'm 18 I'm 19 I don't give a
like what am I worried about I'm
not sitting there being educated about
it but then all of a sudden when it's no
longer about your life when you have a
kid you look at everything in a
different way mhm when you don't have a
kid all you're trying to do is make
money and like have some kind of
influence power Freedom control that you
can you know do whatever things you want
to do once you have kids and friends say
hey did you guys do this no we didn't do
it here's why read this pamphlet oh
babe what are we going to do with oh so
how about this or what are you guys
going to when it comes on to what are
you going to do with this how you going
to hand circum these are all decisions
that all of a sudden now you have to
make you didn't think about that until
you have kids so I understand when
you're single no kids not married yeah
I'll take it and I'll say do do stuff
with the money but you're getting other
guys that are watching the that may
be saying if he's taking it I'll take it
as well anyways we don't need to stay
here we just found out this guy made 20
million bucks off of fizer okay po good
po by the way so so Kobe what's next
with you like right now what are you
thinking are you
thinking at this point with fight where
uh I think you ask for a rematch right
you want to have a rematch with Leon so
you're thinking rematch with him uh uh
is that the main focus you have to get
him to want to do a rematch I mean not
to get him to get the UFC on board that
they need to sell this rematch they
they're going to see that my doctor
tells them that literally my foot was
broken within the first minute of the
fight and you know I I I out landed him
in strikes I double the strike count you
know like I I feel like I had uh I
thought I feel like I won the fight so
that's all I'm going to do whatever it
takes to win the fight if I have to win
10 more fights to get back to him that's
how hungry I am I'm not like one of
these guys like Zion Will Williamson
where he gets a contract and he just
loses his motivation you know he he
already got paid he he's not hungry no
amount of money money is going to take
away my hunger and passion and drive for
this Sport and and for the platform that
I love you know my platform stands for
First Responders stands for military it
stands for the trump it stands for the
troops so I'm going to keep fighting
with those guys on my back and I'm not
done yet they they could say whatever
they want they could say oh I'm past my
Prime I'm not past my Prime dude I'm
just hitting my Prime because I took
good care of my body I didn't Spar hard
I didn't you know go get my my hit head
hit recklessly or I've never been
knocked out so you know like I'm just
getting started in my career and I'm I'm
going to keep fighting it and I want
that rematch what did Zion do to you
like you brought in Z like that was such
a I was I mean I'm just saying he's one
of those lazy undisciplined athletes
he's one of those guys like they get
these paychecks and and they just lose
their hunger you know they just look at
how much weight he's gained the guy just
I mean he's aat fat slob you know he
didn't lose his hunger the one thing he
didn't lose it was the
he that chrisr he's got a pretty good DM
game he's dming everybody nowadays he's
he's apparently wants to get he wants to
be the go ahead of Sean Kamp and Brian
mcnight but that's that's a different
conversation that we brought those two
guys up so but but going going back to
this with the you know wanting to come
back and fight for you after uh the
world is done with after the world of
UFC's done with are you thinking what
you're going to be doing like are you
you know because right after all these
Sports it's typically to be specifically
UFC the guys that don't have
personalities man they don't know how to
make money yeah they don't have any
options on how to make money true where
do I go to literally the only thing you
can do is be an instructor somewhere
making 100 bucks 200 bucks an hour
you're training other people if you can
get paid that right true but those that
have a personality do you see you know I
you know sitting next to Joe like you
you're commentating on stories do you
see kind of maybe your dedication to the
game you're going to open up your own
comington gym and train what do you see
happening to you after UFC have you you
thought about that I haven't thought
about it because I'm still 100% in the
UFC and I I I feel like you know when
you start putting that one foot out and
start thinking about what's next then
you should probably retire you're not
still completely invested into fighting
so I still know I'm one of the best
fighters in the world you know I just
went five rounds with with the supposed
Champion you know who's who who was
supposed to just completely decimate me
and it was a very competitive fight
could have went either way so you know I
know that I am more than just a fighter
though I'm not just a fighter that shows
up and fights in in the
in in the Octagon that's not all I can
do you know I'm smarter than that I can
use my mind and I have intellect to be
able to navigate the waters and get me
where I want to go in life but I haven't
thought about it I do want to get into
politics one day because I want to fight
for what I believe in you know I want to
get into Congress maybe Senate maybe
something like that maybe be the
governor of Florida that would be my
Ultimate Dream to be the governor of
this state get out of here I vote for
you really so you want to be a governor
of Florida I do you know those are my
dreams interesting so what what do you
think about the uh Matt Gates a lot of
people are saying Matt Gates could could
be the next governor of Florida after
Des Sanz yeah you know I think Matt's
he's a great personality he's a very
smart witted guy and you know he's had
you know there there's definitely some
things that I've seen him vote on that I
didn't completely agree with but you
know no one's perfect you actually
follow this stuff you actually follow
the the political how how much do you
follow how intently are you following
issues yeah I mean issues not I mean you
know I'll check X and I and I get all my
issues there because I can't check the
fake news we know the fake news will try
and tell you that the world burning and
that uh you know that everything is is
fine you know and just to live live your
life normally and not worry about
inflation hitting skyrocketing prices or
our border being completely open and
terorists coming through it every single
day so you know I pay attention but I'm
also like you know I don't want to start
going full in until my career is over
and I can dedicate my whole time to it
Governor Covington you know you know
that you know have we there ever has
there ever been an MMA professional
fighter running for high levels of
office has that ever happened no no but
Jessie Ventura was a governor but he was
a wrestler but like with with him no
because like I can imagine you like
debating you're like and like you like
cameras are off and you're like I will
you up no no by the way the line
ends up with and by the way if you have
a problem with me we can handle it you
want to go outside let's go outside
let's go hell there's an element of that
about you're you're in Florida you know
you're you're obviously on on team Trump
uh Governor Des Sanz I assume you voted
for him um you didn't vote for DeSantis
no I didn't vote for Des santis oh St I
mean that was in
2022 um what are your thoughts on his
his situation with Trump these days he
was super close with them in the polls
now it's a landslide do you think Maga
would ever get behind the santis what
are your what's your anticipation there
no magga never forgets you know we once
you expose yourself for being a certain
way he's an establishment puppy you know
he's he's sponsored by George Soros I
mean the guy's an unloyal and Unfaithful
human being let me like if if it wasn't
for Donald Trump endorsing him for
governor of Florida he would never be
the Florida governor so for him to try
and come run against Trump when he had
no chance from the start is just the
most despicable thing alive like you you
have the rest of your life this is
Trump's last shot to save America he's
the last thing that's standing between
communism and capitalism Donald Trump is
loves this country more than he loves
his own money like in his own business
and his own life and his own family like
why couldn't he just step aside and let
Trump have this last hurah you know like
he's got the rest of his life to to run
for politics so it just shows he's an
unloyal Unfaithful person and and Maga
will never forget what he's done to to
Trump and try and throw him under the
bus and the fact that he's not
condemning Colorado for taking Trump off
the ballot that just shows how dangerous
and and just how bad of a person he is
like you think that's okay that's
unconstitutional that's that's not
that's not a democracy that's straight
up communism that's straight up
dictatorship and the fact that he's not
condem just shows what type of person he
is and we'll never forget that are you
following the primaries you see what's
going on with the santis Nikki vet Chris
Christie somehow still there um Trump
hasn't showed up yet what are your
thoughts on what's going on with the
primaries and if Trump somehow wasn't
the candidate in some other life who
would you would you what are your
thoughts on VC what are your thoughts on
Nikki what are your thoughts yeah I mean
you know I think Trump has run away with
the primary there is no primary it's
it's the party of trump so you know he's
he's going to it's it's a landslide he's
beating Biden the polls and that's why
they're trying to find every different
way to take him off the ballots because
they know they can't beat him fair up
you know they they know that he's a
threat and and that they can't stop him
so you know he's the last thing that
stands with us and this being a full out
tyrannical government so you know if if
Trump wasn't on the ballot say but you
know he's going to win this nomination
he's going to make America great again
but if he wasn't you know I like the
things that Vivic is saying I think
think he stands for truth I like that
he's backing Trump and you know he's
condemning you know Colorado taking him
off the ballot because that's that's
unconstitutional that's not democracy so
you know I think Vivic is doing a great
job smart guy he's you know Tech guy
he's made a lot of money he's done good
business and that's what we need we
don't need these political figures that
talk so politically oh everything has to
be politically perfect no we need these
smart business people that understand
how business Works cuz that's what's
going to help America stop sending all
our money out of the country let's put
America first again no one's done that
you know they're trying to destroy this
country they want this country to be
rotting you know and and a lot of people
would be letting this country raw and
just enjoy the money on the sidelines
but not Trump he he cares about this
country more than he cares about life
itself and he's willing to put himself
in the fire and he's the biggest fighter
America's ever had he's going to bite
down his mouthpiece he's going to come
out here fighting and he's going to take
down the swamp God bless Donald Trump
Rob I just sent you a video if you can
pull this video up this is the part
where the santis is being asked uh about
Vic's pledge like hey here's what
vivec's doing what do you want to do are
you willing to agree to this and a lot
of people are saying this is a bad look
but I wonder what you guys think about
this goe and play this
clip and real quick fellow GOP 2024
presidential candidate VC ramaswami
saying he will remove himself from the
Colorado ballot unless Trump's
eligibility is restored would you do the
same no I think that's just playing into
the left um I think the case will get
over turned by the Supreme Court but
I've qualified for all the ballots I'm
competing in all the states and I'm
going to accumulate the delegates
necessary that's the whole name of the
game in this situation but I do
anticipate that that decision was
political and will get reversed what do
you think about the answer all right
what do you think about the answer what
do you think about that when you hear
him saying he's not even answering he's
kind of he's looping around it he's he's
not showing whether he stands up and
supports that and and believes that's
fair or not he doesn't give an answer
and that that's kind of what Ron does he
doesn't really give straight answers he
kind of Beats around the answer to try
and appease to his handlers the people
that are his donors and paying him all
this money you know the guy's he's sold
out to the left now everybody can see
that he's being we think he sold out to
the left I think so I I've seen some of
his biggest donors were George Sor
George Soros Affiliates so you have to
look into that I'm santis backed by
Soros that's the first time I've heard
that by the Affiliates he's saying who's
that some Affiliates some donors of of
Soros have got in infiltrated uh
desantis's camp and and uh who else I
haven't heard of that yet uh uh Dan
santis plans Wall Street fundraiser with
former Soros
executive
wowe breaking some news here buddy
fundraiser ex including former partner
truth is a force in nature yeah and and
and so Kobe like when and he mentioned
uh VC and you said you know Tech Guy and
because I mean VC is taking a page out
of you know Trump's book like he's this
guy like and we we've talked about this
before he kind of came out the gates Co
he was chill he wasn't going hard and
then by the what the third third debate
he's trashing everybody we just saw him
um what was what was the thing Pat that
made uh van Jones shiver or or shake
what was that one Rob whatever it was
Kobe he said I think it it was when he
went after that Ron McDaniel in the GOP
called out called out to face went to
them and went out and and and and and uh
they came after him and Van Jones is
like oh I was shaking but that's the
type of attitude and I think we talked
about this P if you don't mind we play
yeah because so um play whates said and
then play Vic responding to it yeah do
you have are we going to show VC doing
the oh yeah the response yeah this is
what he said this is what van Jones said
about uh VC and the smug condescending
way that he just spewed this poison out
is very very dangerous because he won't
stop Trump but he's going to outlive
Trump by about 50 years and you're
watching the rise of an American
demagogue that is a very very despicable
person and I I literally I I was I was
shaking listening to him talk because a
lot of people don't know that is one
step away from Nazi propaganda coming
out of his mou okay from an Indian yeah
I can't believe that like that's
ridiculous and and then and then this is
his response this is response so I say
that on that last debate stage to a
bunch of Republicans that are shaking in
their boots these are the things you're
not supposed to say in the Republican
Party even today and then you get the
mainstream media you got this character
van Jones on CNN afterwards saying this
is the rise of an American demagogue
who's going to live 50 years longer than
Trump this is dangerous I am shaking
that's what he
says just shut the up wow I've
never
heard amazing just shut the up wow
now hold on I want to ask I want to ask
you but we talked about this in the in
the prep a couple days ago Patrick what
you did you're not a fan of that you're
not a fan of VC going like as a
presidential candidate you're not a fan
of that I I don't know I think I think
there's a difference Vic's already
making so many strides uh on how much
he's come up yes you know two days ago
he made the most viral video on TW on X
for a single day he had 150,000 200,000
likes that thing got 1050 million views
when he's saying I'm not going to be I'm
going to be removing myself from the
Colorado and I'm pledging and I'm
challenging my peers you know Haley and
all these other guys to do the same as
well where's it at now can you 20
million views look at that 16.8 million
views 200,000 likes you know he's just
sitting there from his you know RV
saying this I don't think a presidential
candidate should get up there and saying
what he said UFC MMA all the other stuff
fine I I don't know if a presidential
candidate should go up there say
something like that you know I can see
see how it could rally a young audience
if you're speaking to a private young
audience but you have to know everything
you say someone's going to see it in
today's in today's climate nobody gives
a anymore when you're cursing it's
no longer what it was 20 years ago so I
get that part it's been dehumanized like
it's no longer as it's been desensitized
than what it was before I still don't
don't like him saying it you don't you
don't like and and I I the only reason I
disagree is because at what point and I
know you're going to agree like enough
is enough Trump is going to God willing
for these four years but when he's done
we're this is this is our our next
product I'm thinking of the future but
it's like if he's the future it's like
we the left and they're they're starting
it again with him how long we to let
them get away with it calling somebody
evil let me explain something to you bro
this is what this is what he said and
I'm tired of this acting presidential so
what's acting presidential all the
illegal that they do I I like it
because think about this if somebody
said this to you Kobe
um you're dangerous smug condescending
you spew poison you're an American
demagogue you're a despicable person
dude we've we've hung out with this guy
this saying despicable he's a freaking
family man it's shitty and that he's
speaking one step away from Nazi
propaganda you know what you say to that
shut the up that's what I don't
think so I disagree you disagree but and
let me tell you why I mean what you're
saying will gain you some fans on what
you're saying here so it's a nice thing
for people to say that's why I love V
and d d make you feel good about it but
that's not what leaders do yeah a leader
sits there and says you could give the
same message without having to say that
on that platform because that message
again I've been in a lot of rooms where
I've gotten up and given a talk and I've
gotten hey bro great job dog and hey hey
and I'm like but I lost those two
clients and I lost that person's that
the most loyal person that comes with me
Family Guy Christian guy that's doing
this damn I shouldn't have used those
words and if you're you're not if you
consider yourself wanting to be a leader
amongst leaders who are you leading
you're leading other leaders okay this
is not leading other leaders if you do
it once twice three times fine don't
fall for the Temptation I just hope this
doesn't become a this doesn't become a
trend what we're hearing it next week
and an interview and in a podcast and a
this and a that this you think he'd be a
a multiple occasion saying the f word or
was it cuz TP he was at the America Fest
and younger crowd and
you've been around me you've heard me
curse it's not like I curse I'm not
sitting here telling you I don't or I do
you know when you first came to us your
brand was a different brand when you
content you like what are you doing yeah
you don't need to you don't need to do
this stuff to make people laugh just
because cuz sometimes here's sometimes
if you're not too careful your
reputation is what everybody says your
reputation is and you stay loyal to what
other people keep sane you are and
that's a you're in a you're you're
arrested you're in a prison you're in a
what do you call it you're like spider
whip that's got a hold of you and then
it could be like you're the clown you're
the fighter you're the gangster you're
the you're the thief you're the bully
you're the this you're the that and
you're like dude that was when I was 18
years old that was when I was 32 I'm 45
years old no I'm not that anymore you
know that's when I was that and you have
to find a way to not fall for that trap
there's an audience that wants him to
say this but who is that audience the 2%
the 8% the 13% what about the other side
that you need it now we you one time
fine means you're capable of losing your
means you're human human being
totally fine if this becomes the brand
moving forward I don't Trump said it a
couple times on stage and I like it when
he said it a couple times rarely I
actually like it and he said it a couple
times I just don't think it has to be
consistent I hope it doesn't yeah I I I
I agree what I'm saying is though think
about what was said about him I'm not
going to lie to you I probably would
have gone even worse but that's why you
you got to be careful though because if
you if you're if you're trying to be a
president we can say if that would have
done it to me I would have done such and
such okay before having a daughter my
biggest fear was what am I going to do
when I have a daughter and a guy is
going to hook up with my daughter and
date my daughter and I'm sleeping at
night and they're still at the movies
and as a man your creative mind is going
where yeah of course think about that
right of so first place you go to I'm
going to pull off a Will Smith and hey
you're going to come to the house and
he's going to be like hey you like man
you ever been with a man you want to
right you know Will Smith comes out and
is De with you know which movie is this
by the way boad bo bo to
right I'm going to have to have somebody
come out there and do this you you're 17
you look like you're 30 yeah uh so are
you going to and then eventually you're
like well if you raise them well you
show them love you give them an example
and and they get to choose they're going
to have their heartbroken at some point
or another you have to kind of work with
that right but if you want to be that
tough guy gangster beating everybody up
for the rest of your life your upside is
limited so yes I get what you're saying
I understand it it's exciting but look
at this that comment he said didn't go
viral and look at this comment 20
million you know why cuz this made sense
this makes he didn't curse one time you
didn't say this makes sense and people
listen to it to the point where he's
cornering the santis to answer and he
knows what the SST is going to say yeah
you understand what I'm saying he knows
they're going to go to the santis and
he's going to be asked that question and
the santis is going to say no and mag's
going to see it he knows what he's doing
do this he can outs School his peers
staying in this mode not in the other
mode the other mode is Temptation again
I could be wrong it's my opinion that's
all I'm saying if you see yourself as a
leader amongst leaders you have to pump
the brakes when it comes down to certain
approaches you take take yeah I Kobe
what do you think yeah I mean I think
you know they're pulling nasty things
out of their playbook you know the
things that they're doing taking him off
a ballot for nothing he was ever even
convicted of this is just you know not
even a crime that he ever did and so
this is this is this is terrible
Behavior so I think the gloves are
coming off and there's no more fair
fight we can't be nice we need to be
Stern we need to be you know up front I
mean you look at Elon the way he went
after the guys that were pulling back
all those funs off the X and he said
what do he say get the out of here
go yourself yourself you know
like I'm okay with that yeah yeah I'm
totally okay with that he's not running
for a presidental that's the only
difference it's different you know so I
do feel like you're probably right you
know when you're in that political
position running for a presidential
position like you still need to make
Middle America happy and Middle America
you know they don't want people cussing
and and doing those types of things
because that's not a good example for
their kids so yeah there's ways that he
could come across a lot stronger without
having to say say that so I do agree on
that front but we also we're not being
playing Fair anymore they're not playing
by the rules you know they've opened up
by the way and they never will that's
our job let us do it you don't need to
do that okay you know I was I was on
Whose show I was at guy asked me a
question he says you got advice for
Trump what would you give like you don't
give advice to a guy like that you know
when you make it at that level he's not
taking but he is a what do you mean guy
he takes a lot of it so Charlie Kirk
asked me this question at the event
Turning Point you said when I'm doing
his podcast last week I said only thing
I would say is the following here's what
I would say when you're a boss you're
lucky
luchano when you are you know Roger
godell okay of NFL when you are Dana
White when you are go to the bosses the
boss amongst bosses
okay you're going to have more enemies
than anybody else you're already dealing
with your kid issues your family issues
your personal health issues that nobody
knows about your marriage you got so
much other you're dealing with that
no one knows about and you can't ever
talk about that with anybody else
because nobody gives a quite
frankly it's like that's your problem or
handle your problem but if you're going
to be a boss amongst bosses you list out
your enemies 50 of them Trump's got
thousands but let's just say you list
out your top 50 enemies and you know
what you do here's what you do guys I'm
going after one 2 3 4 5 you're going
after 6 9 14 28 Patrick you're going to
go do this Vinnie you're going to go do
this and you're like dude I got 28 a
matter of fact I want 28 right give
me but but the way this is is you're
playing defense dude I want to freaking
lock him up I want to guard him I got
him right where sometimes Michael's like
no no no I'm locking him up like the one
wants to lock up the one right all I'm
saying is that's our job you know
whoever when I say our job whoever's not
running you you know that's somebody
else that's your job to go fight for a
guy like that it's office Elon Musk what
he did freaking 10 out of 10 go Dana
White 10 out of 10 go but they're not
running for office that office is an
office that was held by you know
Lincoln's room you all these other guys
that have come before us there's a level
of respect we have to have for those
guys that's all I'm saying I love the
fact that he's capable because when you
know someone's capable you can sit there
and say all right that guy could cross
the line next time okay I like a little
capability but you just need to be a
little bit of work again that's my
opinion uh did you have a follow-up you
look like you wanted to ask Kobe
something well I think it's a perfect
segue for you're talking enemies and who
to attack and who not to attack I just I
want to know what happened with midal
because I mean I know you want to go um
you know fight uh Leon again uh Jon
Jones you've had some words with that's
that's a bad man right there Colby Dana
White Joe Rogan you said you'd smack
Rogan a little bit you got a lot going
on comington but mval I'm so and so
intrigued cuz I'm a Miami guy I've seen
that guy fighting for years uh back in
the Kimbo Slice days if I'm sure you
know all about that um you guys had your
dust up poppy steak shout out to Groot
Hospitality down there in Miami those
are my boys down there obviously
everything that happened there but what
happened bro you guys were were friends
you guys lived together you guys roomed
together he said you slept on his couch
for eight months I'm just using his
words um you guys were sort of BFFs he
said he was his mentor and then you know
one of you guys chose your enemy
speaking of choose your enemies
wisely now he says you're a sellout he
called you a he's saying all this
you guys were on Stephen A Smith
you you had the sunglasses on I'm too
pretty these girls are GNA fall in love
what happened with Mosel I beat him up I
gave him the 5043 in a soda it was the
easiest fight in my career I can't
believe they paid me what they paid me
to beat that backstab and bum up he's a
backstabber he's a guy that you know as
soon as I started rising up in the ranks
that's when it was an issue that's when
he his ego came in he's like no you
Kobe I'd fight you for I'd fight my mom
for money so I'm for sure going to fight
you we're going to fight one day and
then he just he just started throwing me
under the bus for no reason like he just
started talking in media when we
weren't even scheduled to fight yet or
even talking about fights and it's so
crazy cuz like we lived together for
like you know a couple years you know I
lived on his wife's couch Marissa the
the woman that he has two kids with that
he doesn't pay child support to cuz he's
a piece of dead beat dad like I
said so that's why he got offended did
cuz I hit the truth and he had whatever
he could do whatever he wanted to be in
that UFC Octagon legally for 25 minutes
he couldn't do that was the easiest
fight I didn't even break a sweat in
that fight I was laughing the end it he
had two guys holding him
up yeah like just completely exhaust the
guy's a bum so yeah he had to come
outside of that Steakhouse in Miami
Beach and he had to stalk me sit in the
bushes and come and hit me in the back
of the head and then knock my tooth out
because he hit me in the back of the
head concuss me he's a world he's a
world class fighter and you know he
couldn't beat me legally so he had to do
it illegally and he's a cheap shot
artist how can you respect a scumbag
like that look at his past history he's
stolen cards arson like the guy's a
felon you know like there's multiple
things of him saying you know oh
Kobe in the magga movement back in the
past but now he's you know best friends
with the Maga and he he thinks he's a
represent uh representative of of the
Republicans so people see right through
him he's a criminal he's a slime bag
he's a backstabber he has a ego you know
most people in this sport they have an
ego they can't let their OS to the side
I I never had a problem with him he just
started throwing me under the bus and he
said hey I I got to hate the people I
fight so it is what it is is he at the
top of your list of your your enemies
list like is he the if there's one guy
you're like dude I don't even want to
paycheck for this I'll fight for free
who's at the is he at the top of the
list I mean not really I I've let all
you know feelings and emotions go with
that guy I could care less about him
I've already handled my business in the
UFC people saw in front of the world
what I did to them you know I played
with them I was slapping him I was
saying who's your daddy he in the
fight in the fight in his ear I was
whispering he couldn't do anything I was
whispering letting him know hey I'm your
big brother I'm your daddy who's your
daddy George so I have nothing you know
he's I'm levels above him you know in in
every sense of the word you know
politically uh spiritually in in the
sports world like he he's retired why
are we even talking about a guy that's
not even at the top I'm still you know a
top contender in the UFC and and future
champion this division so now we're
talking about a washed up scrub that
you know had two seconds of Fame he hit
lightning in a bottle and then we're
going to talk about him being a good
fighter he's not a good Fighter the guy
has double digit losses on his record
his winning record he's like a 50% win
winner he wins one fight loses a fight
wins a fight we're talking about him
like this guy's a nobody so I
you know I've let my all my emotions and
feelings go with that guy cuz I have
nothing else to prove to him you know
he's I've already proved that in the
octagon and I Expos the piece of
person he was he talks about his Maga
but he he had an a obam phone for years
like how how do you believe in in
freedoms but you're getting food stamps
and an obam phone and you're getting all
these government assisted handouts but
then you're going to preach against it
like you stand for conservatism no that
doesn't make sense you're a hypocrite so
you know people he got exposed and I
exposed in front of the whole world and
I've moved on from that it's it's bigger
business and I got bigger fish to fry
Kobe who are your friends who do you
have as friends who would you say like
these are my friends that we have each
other's back who would you say those are
my best my my best friend you know is a
guy named Charlie Weiss you know he's a
sergeant of the Miami Beach Police
Department the guy literally saved my
life on stage last week and people don't
even realize this I I got done doing my
intervie viiew with Joe Rogan on Friday
night after we weighed in it was our
last face off with Leon Leon Scott
before we were going to fight for the
Undisputed title the next day I get off
and there were so many people on stage
so it was like very crowded so we were
like towards the front where Joe Rogan
was interviewing me and I get done with
the interview and I'm like yeah this
one's for America and I was just like
the lights are so bright and all the
people were screaming I I go to walk off
the stage and freaking Charlie grabs me
on the back of my shirt my next step was
going off the platform cuz you have to
we had to like I was going to go off the
stage right here but the stairs were
over here I had to go over to the left
no one was looking out for me no
security nobody only Charlie and this is
a guy that's a police officer that
that's you know fought for our army
that's been done tours and and he's an
established guy the guy most people
would be so caught up in that moment
that they wouldn't even they would have
let me fall off I would have broke every
bone in my body it was a 9 ft freaking
drop I had to go down 10 stairs oh damn
yeah so this is a guy who really cares
about me doesn't get caught up in the
moment truly watching my back at all
times like a brother would and I
consider this guy family I would take a
bullet for this guy he's he's blood he's
he's more than family and you know he's
my best friend who I care about who else
in the UFC world who else in the
fighting world in the fighting world you
know I I don't have friends because you
know I always said you know I'm not here
to make friends I'm here to make money
and and that's what matters to to me is
financially changing uh my future and my
family's future I've been able to do
things for my family get them things
that they would have never been able to
get otherwise so you know everybody's
jealous of me they hate the way I do
business but they're not making the
checks I'm making they're making basic
pay you know and they'll be broke in a
couple years I'm set for life do you
think that's the right approach do you
think you're taking a right approach
with relationships what do you think
because to me uh uh you know I had a guy
that I was doing business with never
forget what he told me in Atlanta one
time he says look this is how I am man
I'm going to destroy everybody I'm going
to hate on everybody I'm going to kill
everybody and then years later uh when
I'm so far ahead from them then I'm
going to try to be friends with them I'm
like I don't know if that strategy is
going to work because at the end of the
day when you're like even in the NBA
right like my guy is Kobe okay I've had
Kobe on we've spent time together I I
just I relate to Kobe Kobe went through
a phase where as a villain I mean his
Nick name right black mamba after all
the stuff that happened with you know
incidents Colorado stuff that happens
this is how you guys want to do no
problem and guess who gave him the name
black mamba himself right it wasn't like
others gave him the name no I am the
Black Mamba and then he put a whole
Persona around it like you know Bosworth
used to be the nicest guy I don't know
if you've ever seen the Bosworth
documentary if you've never seen I think
you would really like it if you've not
seen it phenomenal documentary called B
you ever seen a documentary yeah Brian
BOS from Oklahoma it's him and his son
it's him and his son and going through
the old material and they're doing it
when he's in his late 50s early 50s type
of thing it's actually it's worth you
watching it by yourself without anybody
else around right okay and then all of a
sudden coob Kobe comes into the league
and you know in the Olympics he tells
Carmelo Anthony and LeBron if I come
across the center and I see pal galz
putting up a screen I'm going to run
right through him have you ever seen
this clip or no I've heard about it he
runs runs right through him as if he's
tackling can you show it for him but not
the audience so whoever's in the back
don't share the clip because I think
it's we're going to get flaged but I
want the player who's the player youve
never seen Kobe run through Pal Gasol in
the Olympics by the way they were
teammates on the Lakers oh they're still
teammates on the Lakers oh yeah and he
runs through him boom I it looks like he
they could have given him a technical
foul kicked him out of the game that's
how bad it was powers on the ground is
like what was that why why and ising
chion if you can if you can actually do
this instead of doing 2.0 go to 1.0 uh
uh but just go to the clip just fast
forward a little bit to the clip keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going you're about to see it uh
right there it's coming up right there
back up three seconds back up three
second right there so watch this pow
screen Kobe boom Oh DN drops him and he
goes rocks and he tell people he was
going to do that right yeah why why
because did you see what he said right
before that though he goes how close you
guys he's like we're like brothers we're
teammates they won an NBA championship
together says I'm running right through
his ass so the question is you know when
you're in it and you know Michael had a
relationship Charles Oakley he was
friends with these guys right eventually
becomes lonely when you're going through
it especially if the the G if the game
you're in and the older you get the more
you value relationships yeah it's
important to make money of course yeah
it's important to have a legacy very
important but
you you want to be able to sit there and
have friends where you're talking
to they can talk to you you can
talk to them you're laughing you're
talking about different things and you
can reminisce and go through that do you
value at that at all with people within
the space that you've been competing in
for all these years not within the space
because a lot of Fighters are very
small-minded they only did fighting
because they had no other reason to make
it out an outlet and a platform you know
these are the guys that were fighting in
backyard so they just decided to fight
you don't see a lot of Fighters that
have you know very good degrees or or
have an education they're just all they
know how to do is oh testosterone let's
fight you know and that's never been me
so my friend and my support group is
outside the fighting Circle I don't I
don't want to have friends in the
fighting Circle because the people in
the fighting fighting circle circle
their perspectives are completely
different than mine they don't think
that the way I think they don't they
don't approach business the way I
approach business so I don't really want
to be friends with those and and for me
I like to have a disc conect when I'm
not fighting I don't want to be thinking
about fighting I want to talk about
politics I want to talk about life I
want to talk about the future because
there's a reason that the windshield is
bigger than the rearview Mir I don't
want to talk about what happened
yesterday or what happened in my tii I
want to talk about what's going to
happen right here in the moment so I get
that and and and and again look I'm 45
so if I sit down and talk to a guy
that's a billionaire and he's 65 and I
want to see what he's going to give me
feedback wise I'll entertain it and it's
beneficial to talk to somebody like that
right so let's say maybe in your world
that would be a Daniel for me or because
whatever he's like ahead of you and and
he's one when I say ahead of you age
wise he's ahead of you in you know I
don't know how old Daniel is I'm going
to say he's 42 how how old say 40 say 41
no 43 44 he fought Stipe when he was 41
okay there you go okay so he's 44 years
old so I I you know when I see uh the
relationship with you know Cormier I see
him with Rogan I see him with j i see
him with these guys guys are sitting
there you're seeing some of these
Fighters later on their friends and
they're hanging out together all this
stuff there this is a phase of your
career right
so snipers sometimes they're loners m in
the military you know the SP sniper
mightet they don't have friends yeah but
even a sniper's got a guy laying next to
him to saying hey go do this way go do
this go do that go do that go do this um
you don't process that at all where you
know some because dude you you haven't
been one of the guys that fought you're
one of the main guys that we've you know
like that's been in this space that's
brought a lot of eyeballs to it you're
not just another UFC fighter you know I
know you don't think about that yourself
I'm just telling you as a fan side
you're not just another UFC fighter
you're like one of the main names of
this brand right that you know all these
different Avengers are coming up and
different villains and all these roles
that they play but even inside of a
villain man he's got a heart you know
the villain is sitting there saying man
you know relationships some of these
guys I've gone to battle with I wouldn't
mind you know maybe sitting down and
chopping it up with some of these guys
yeah you did some I got my stuff on
my you know cuz you don't walk on water
I don't walk on water the other doesen
person doesn't walk on water so we can
sit here and talk to each other but
just as much as you know they're dirt
they probably know I don't know your
dirt cuz I'm not in your world right but
in my world when we're competing
everybody knows each other's dirt
everybody knows like what are you
talking about you want me to bring up
that story from 2004 and what you did
like what are you talking about remember
that one time you did this so there's
got to be that element as well you you
don't see the benefit of having any
friendships with any of these guys no I
mean I have one friendship I I I you
know I was mistaken you know the guy
that got me into mixed martial arts a
guy by the name of CHA P sonen that's my
mentor in the MMA space that's my friend
in the MMA space I've gotten a lot of
advice from him over the years very cool
he got me into fighting originally he
was getting ready for the Anderson Sila
fights and he came to my college Oregon
State University he's like Kobe I want
to wrestle with you get your pressure
pace and I want you to help train me for
Anders Silva so that was when I got to
sit down with him and understand more to
this business it just wasn't just about
fighting there was more you need to
entertain this a show business so you
know Cha's done a lot for me and I still
get a lot of advice from him and talk
with him on the phone regularly to today
besides that my support systems consists
of doctors dentists lawyers you know
police officers military personnel you
know those are my friends you know my
another one of my best friends Steven
Hodson he was in the 82nd Airborne unit
for the Army Rangers now he's uh with
the golden knights in the Army so you
know these are the people that I look up
to Charlie Weiss at the Miami Beach
police station Kirk Weiss he's a top
lawyer for Chick-fil-A one of the top
lawyers in the world in Miami and Ritter
and Ramsay this dentist up in uh in
Jupiter who did my teeth who you know
these are the type of people that that
are successful that understand business
and and more than just fighting you know
and and that's that's more that's what I
want I want disconnect from this
fighting world and I want to have
friends that you know like you that that
are bigger than than larger than
were you closer grown up uh uh uh to
Pops or Mom I was a mama's boy for sure
you're a mama's boy but close to both
close to both yeah my dad got me in
wrestling so did did anybody hardcore
and I'm I'm not asking for a name but
did anybody
hardcore ever backstab you or betray you
where you're like you know you're like
Tupac don't trust no one did that ever
happen or no that's not at all the case
oh yeah that's happened a couple times
okay and was there one that was above
everything where you made a personal
truth to yourself dude this is it my
loyalty is only to these people and no
one else gets into that Circle and if
you do it's going to take a lot was that
kind of like a moment that you had yeah
it was about the fighter that he brought
up earlier and I'm not going to say his
name anymore cuz I'm over it but that
was what really was the eye opener
someone who I thought was my best friend
who I Liv with and was so close but he
was willing to throw me under the bus
because he cared about his personal gain
and and fame and money more than he
cared about his relationship and yeah
that's
and that's between you guys I don't I
don't want to beat a dead horse it's
just I I wanted to understand you better
uh uh uh because I enjoy watching you I
enjoy watching you fight and I've
enjoyed what you've done thank and I
wanted to get a better understanding
about why you play this villain role bro
I wanted to see why you play this
villain role I don't play a villain role
I I'm I'm just myself I turn it up to 11
I don't care what people think of me I
people can have their own opinion I
respect everybody's opinion in America
and that's what makes this country so
beautiful is that we can all have
descending in different opinions but we
don't all have to think the same exact
thing all the time so you know I respect
everybody's opinion they're entitled to
it I'm not going to shame you or throw
you under the bus because you have a
different opinion than me I want you to
have your own opinion I want you to
think for yourself I think that's fair
and and you're February 22nd right are
you 22nd yeah February 22nd interesting
very interesting memory very interesting
guy very very interesting what can he
say about him because he's obviously one
of the best talkers of all time oh
man started it didn't he was the initial
guy that guy that's our Oregon gangster
the Westland gangster man you don't want
to mess with that guy you walk around
the streets of wesland Oregon man people
don't realize how tough he had it man
that guy's a gangster there was some
years back 20 years ago when his parents
only made 100,000 a year could you
imagine having to live off 100,000 a
year 20 years
ago you saying that he had a easy
upbringing is that's what you're saying
I'm saying he had a tough upbringing man
that's tough man that's that's
100K
poish who who in your eyes who's the
best talker in the UFC is do you
have like a list if you would say top
five who would be on that list top five
you know I like sha UI he's got great
talking these days um besides that
everybody's just they don't they don't
want to open up they don't want to be
judged they want everybody to look at
them in a sympathetic role like they're
the good guy no one wants to step out
and be and be a bad guy and expose the
truth but you know the truth is what
that always hurts and stings the worst
of these Fighters not so much the best
talker not so much you know we've
asked the hardest puncher hardest guy
well I want to know like Swag Like game
like the biggest pimp type dude like I
mean Usman showed up the other day he
was chilling he you got some game you
you know you talking about fashion like
Style just like like a like you know you
know they say a man's man and also you
know guy that most guys want to be like
but girls want to sleep with that kind
of dude he's swagged out he's a pimp
like Ladies Man all that dresses well
looks good who would you put on like the
best game kind of a thing right like
swag type Vibes well I mean definitely
Connor he's he done some great things
you know he's he's one of the biggest
fighters of all time if not the biggest
and you know he kind of changed the the
game you know he he brought in so many
fans that that never watched UFC before
so that's that's there's casual fans and
then there's hardcore fans you know if
he can he brought in all the casuals so
he's got that swag he's done some great
things and he might be a future Prime
Minister I think you know he could do
some good things for Ireland you see the
people you know rotten and burning in
his streets and he's not okay with that
you know he wants those borders secure
just like we need our borders secure
here in America cuz if you don't know
who's coming in I me like that's what's
causing all these crime rates to go up
that's what's causing hundreds of
thousands of kids to die from fenal
every year because these drug lords are
coming in so we need to monitor our
borders and keep our people uh free and
safe what's your relationship with
Conor um no relationship you know I
respect his body of work I think he's
done some great things in the space you
know he's you know the things he did
were unmatchable knocking out Jose Aldo
in 7 Seconds you're not ever going to
see someone do that in the title fight
ever again so you know my uh my
relationship with him is just I respect
him and he's a great fighter he's done
some great things in the sport and you
know I think he's going to go on to do
better things in politics for Ireland
really that would be the most ENT
Minister I might move the
IR imagine his press conferences oh my
God hey what the fu the the are you
doing he could say that and get away
with it all day long his brand they
would love him right yeah of course
that's so funny I want to ask him if
it's okay with you uh you were talking
about is that do you think kobby that
one of the main cuz I I believe in it
that one of the main issues that we're
dealing with and the Biden
Administration with uh mayorcas the you
know the homeland
security horrible horrible little rat um
do you think that's one of our main or
like if not the main issue because I
don't know if you saw uh Governor Abbott
of Texas on Monday signed the bill that
makes entering Texas illegal which thank
God for and and it allows police to
arrest illegals coming into the state
because apparently Homeland Security is
not doing nothing the border patrol
isn't doing nothing uh and in November
did you know this 200,000 illegals have
come in it's up 2% from the from the
month uh previous and think about it
they're not saying nothing uh Kobe
because all those people are coming in
are future votes a lot of these kids are
become slaves uh traffic sex all that
and did you see this Stephen A
Smith made a video and mind you I'm if
they're not doing it and people are just
running over the Border good let the
police stop people and and and check
them out Stephen A Smith made a video
how he's condemning what uh abbid did if
you could play that uh maybe play the
first minute Rob go ahead play the first
minut go to the beginning of it Rob
because yeah go ahead Greg abbid you
ever heard of him yes he's the governor
for the State of Texas come on Ste
there's a fake fire behind you Steve
that governor governor Abbott signed a
bill into law that will allow the police
to arrest migrants illegal enter the US
illegally illegal this law which takes
effect look I'm curious I just want to
read that so my English English is my
fifth language I need your help I got
you Texas Bill makes illegal migration
State Crime isn't illegal immigration a
crime already what are we talking about
what are we talking about it has it in
the name like you ridic like that okay
let him play I love Stephen A I love him
too I love stepen I just talk to him
yeah that's right I've seen just talked
no I just talked to him three days ago
you know he's like Kobe I don't agree
with your politics but but you know I I
agree with what you stand for and I
respect you for your body of work but
you know come on dude everybody knows
he's employed by ESN they're the biggest
wokest company of all yeah Disney so you
know of course he's got to say that
because if he doesn't then his sign his
checks aren't going to get signed so
he's just doing that he doesn't really
believe that he's just doing that to
appease his you know his I agree and
here what do he say here he just says so
you that he know he called it racist he
says it's racist he he says Governor
Abbott is racist he goes he's racist
it's a racist thing which I dude I'm you
nailed well I mean it's five the video
is 5 minutes long but I'll break it down
he says it's racist and he's like so
that means if a cop sees a Latin looking
person they could go and grab him I'm G
like Stephen A Smith stick to sports bro
because you know what he's from New York
I'm from New York go to New York and ask
New Yorkers how they feel about all
these uh illegals that are just bust
over there and flown over there and how
it's going go ask Eric uh Adams how is
it going
because Texas can't dude there have you
been have you seen the Border have you
seen what's happening and it's like
nobody cares and I'm tired of this it's
racist can you pull up the clip of the
boorder because it was a record-breaking
day yesterday you know how many people
yesterday 125 wow 12,500 in a single day
cross the board and by the way you know
what that is times 365 record-breaking 4
and a half it was a record-breaking day
yesterday and we did nothing 45 million
a year if they allowed they were
interviewing who was coming across look
at that is that real
yeah that's real this is yesterday
that's not that's this is not a what do
you call it it was a soccer game and
somebody won not a soccer game no and oh
and and then and Adam before you go and
here's my point and and this is this
really bothered me Rob and I sent the
clip to Rob they don't give a who's
coming in and what's happening Rob I saw
I saw a video that really pissed me off
there's some guys from Guatemala they're
coming over the border and another Latin
guy stops them and questions him about
the kid who looks like he's drug play
this video look they don't even know
that's not their kid watch put the can
you put the volume
up
watch watch
this wake him up wake him up
look that kid look
look he was sleeping watch
this
what year doesn't know the year of of of
the kid that is his kid that's not his
kid and the kid's one years old say the
year prior buddy okay and then here's my
point and then and then another one this
guys this is what we're dealing with
this is one case Adam and then Rob has
another video now in Texas Valley
Airport the now there there's underage
migrants coming in look at how they're
all in cahoots with border patrol watch
this moving these kids
to you guys got paperwork for these kids
don't worry about it you know a third of
these kids go missing look at this dog
you guys know anything about
this about these guys moving these kids
to the
airport look straight up it's America
it's America America that's not America
yo that's America you can stop it Rob so
my my point is get it what's going on
here so these kids are coming in with
and with these these sponsors just
coming in they and where are these kids
going there's no SP they're going to be
put in different they're going to house
them they're going to they're going to
give them money while where our veterans
brought in the streets and when they
disappear nobody's keeping track of the
lost kids and this is just one case and
the guy the border patrol is like yeah
just yeah that's how we go I'm going to
add something to to what you're saying
so you know we were just a turning point
USA we interviewed James o'keef for our
buddy shout out to you James yeah uh he
threw a party the next night we missed
it but we'll do it again soon but him
and my friend Ashley stclair who who was
also there they broke one of the biggest
stories yesterday they had a massive uh
Twitter xace yesterday about what's
going on at the Phoenix Airport where um
they saw these uh migrants being busted
in right they got dropped off at the
airport by James was going in on it by
black limo service weird right here it
is right here by like you know VIP type
buses and he basically starts asking
what's going on here where are these
guys going what's going on they all end
up going to the airport they're all
flying to New York Ashley was flying
from from Phoenix to New York it was a
whole thing migrants on the plane
they're getting taken from the border
black limo service getting sent to these
Sanctuary cities this is New York and
then on Twitter last night or X they had
all the pilots basically half of them
had to disguise their voice yeah and
they're like just what's going on you
know just get to the point here they're
like dude where are the pilots of these
planes and like we don't know who the
hell these people are we don't know
these kids are we don't know what's
going on you know what they use as ID
they don't even have ID they're arrest
records so there's basic people that are
just basically saying maybe go to Ashley
St St Clair's on um you play her video
um there people just basically like guys
what's going on here you know what's
going on open borders yeah just flying
them across the country busting them
here Sanctuary City there this is Ashley
right here if you want to play this is
30 seconds of migrants who are also
boarding this flight that the US
taxpayers are paying for this is what
the us taxpayers are paying for right
here premium seats on Delta that they
have people coming here we're paying for
this shipping them out to New York City
because guess what everywhere else is at
capacity so they have these Sanctuary
cities like New York that they're now
shipping these migrants to that we're
all paying for why though I I I I'm
going to to go off cuz I've said this
before too it's uh first I think it's
votes all over the place but when you're
not keeping track there's no IDE when
they're young and they're whatever a
they're going to be used for cheap ass
labor and I'm going to be honest with
you sex trafficking and all that that
it's an it's a constant influx and
that's why the left is like no we're
humanitarians let them in no no no no
you have to keep the the the Supply open
there's no other excuse give me another
excuse give give me
you think why do you think come on dude
I mean he's definitely on to something
with the the sex trafficking you know if
you saw that movie sound of Freedom it
showed all the the the nasty uh vile
things that are happening to these kids
and you know obviously we all know about
Epstein Island all these left uh Elites
were flying to this island regularly to
to be with little kids so you know
they're about to release those those
flight logs and a lot of people are
going to get exposed so I think that's a
there's a legit pedophile ring in DC and
you know why not get little migrants
from all around the world that they can
just abuse you know what's going to
happen though whoever gets elected next
there there's going to be deporting
going on like the the the amount of
people that came
illegally the conversation is about what
you're going to do to deport guys
they're openly having conversations
right now about that and FYI like if you
lose Texas if I understand strategically
if you're allowing these people into
Texas because that makes sense cuz you
got to you got to turn Texas blue Texas
the biggest pain in the ass for liberals
oh yeah
totally deep red now it's purple no now
it's purple yes now it's purple by way
Texas you lose Texas that's what 30
elect votes Texas becomes purple and and
Florida becomes red which is kind of
weird you know not fully red but you
know in the way of being red right but
why would you move them to New York it's
not like New York needs more liberals
there what are you doing moving them to
New York you know you're not winning
anything with that so strategically I
understand Arizona fine I get it you
have some annoying people that are there
for the left they can't stand a Car Lake
I understand Texas yeah totally get it
you want to get rid of uh you know what
uh uh Abbott is doing and with some of
the other guy but moving them to Blue
cities intention don't know and they're
not saying nothing about it it's just
happening isn't that weird nothing about
it yeah well I mean look again this will
be more of a reason because there's
certain issues
Vinnie that unifies the entire party for
example not the entire party the entire
country you may be pro-life okay and she
may be pro-choice right and whatever you
can make the argument for pro-life
pro-choice you know what the midterm
showed last year majority of America are
pro-choice you give me pro life all you
want midterm showed majority America's
pro-choice so guess what Republicans you
screwed up okay oh okay we paid the
price should have been a red wave didn't
get a red wave mhm now liberals may be
saying oh I bet everybody wants more Dem
more people to come down the Border no
even Democrats living in those cities
raising kids don't want to open borders
okay that's the part where America is
against open borders hey everybody
should be okay with us teaching lgbtq
stuff in school no not everybody is
parents are on the same side with this
2024 election if there's no game game
gamesmanship and no
manipulation it's going to be a it's
going to be it's going to be a landslide
if there's no gamesmanship the only way
there won't be a landslide is because
there's gamesmanship because the entire
America doesn't stand for this stuff
Dems don't stand for this stuff the
people on the left don't stand for this
stuff John fedman talking I'm not a
progressive yeah I'm at the insurance
we're having dinner you know who was at
the dinner at the main table don't say
the names but you know who was sitting
at the table with you and I right at the
Diplomat you're saying
so we're sitting there one of the guys
sitting next to him he's a very good
friend of mine love this guy but he's a
he's a liberal he can't stand Trump
cannot stand Trump right he's a liberal
and he went to All the Right schools
okay he has all the right gpas when I
say right schools I mean like the ivy
league type of schools like all that
stuff right and he guess where he lives
he lives in grenwich Connecticut you
know house Sag Harbor like that kind of
stuff and he's saying look man I'm not
going to lie to you what the way the
liberal the Le is handling the Jewish
Community I don't know it's making me
want to consider voting the other side
for the first time in my life there's so
many
dumb strategies that the left is playing
that they think they 100% have loyalty
of everybody on the left and they don't
I'm convinced they don't and I think
they're going to show it at 2024 I
believe that but again we'll see and
they're going to play all these games
they're going to play it is what it is
Kobe it's been a bless having you on man
really really enjoy talking to you
appreciate for coming on apprciate you
and uh uh gang I am we we're not doing
any podcast today's what the 21st the
next time we do another podcast will be
in
2024 which pbd
yes I want to wish I want to wish all
you guys a Merry Christmas a happy New
Year and may 2024 be the beginning of
the greatest years of your life God
bless everybody take care bye- bye bye-
bye